major controversy over megyn kelly and
her new program on NBC News choosing to
interview conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
of Infowars Fame the background on this
entire megyn kelly last year or so is of
course she was at Fox News she had a
controversy with Donald Trump or Donald
Trump alluded to her bleeding out of her
genitals during a debate or in
retrospect after a debate or whatever
then she was involved in the Roger Ailes
controversy where she came out and said
hey I know about some of the stuff Roger
Ailes did and then some criticized her
saying she as a major voice on Fox News
should have come out earlier on in the
investigation and then the big news was
megyn kelly is leading Fox News and she
has this blockbuster major new weekly
show to air on NBC News on Sunday nights
she launched it with really a pretty
interesting interview with Russian
leader Vladimir Putin very well done
asked a lot of interesting questions and
now she is under fire because this
Sunday night on the next episode of her
show she is interviewing conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones some people are
disgusted some people are angry some
people are saying Alex Jones should not
be provided a platform because of his
views etc etc so you know my view if
you've been watching or listening to the
show for a while which is I don't really
believe in no platforming for the sake
of no platforming because someone's
views are offensive or whatever the case
may be
I've interviewed the Westboro Baptist
Church people when they were relevant i
interviewed all right white nationalist
leader Richard Spencer because his
movement was so relevant in the election
of Donald Trump some people criticize me
for the former some people criticize me
for the latter and I've defended it what
do I think about megyn kelly doing this
particular interview with Alex Jones I
will tell you but first let's just look
at a clip from the interview this is a
preview of that interview that's been
released again the full episode will air
on Sunday evening we call you the most
paranoid man in America is that true
absolutely not a paranoid person will be
hiding out in their house not venturing
out in public I go out there on the
street battle black lives matter the
communists point-blank range we talk to
controversies
and conspiracies 911 now 9/11 was an
inside job but when I say inside job it
means criminal elements in our
government working with Saudi Arabia and
others wanted to frame Iraq for it just
a fact
Sandy Hook well Sandy hooks complex
because I've had debates where we
devil's advocate said the whole story is
true that I've had to base where I've
said that none of it's true when you say
parents faked their children's death
people get very angry well that's all I
know but they don't get angry about the
half million Iraqis from sanctions or
they don't get angry about all these
guys no no it's not a dodge the media
never covers all the evil Wars it's
promoted all that doesn't excuse what
you did instead about Newtown no I
here's a difference I looked at all the
angles of Newtown and I made my
statements long before the media even
picked up on it we didn't get any the
really important stuff what do you mean
we talk about all the important stuff
here's the big one always make funny
probably throw this in here thirty years
ago they began creating animal-human
hybrids is it that the big story megyn
kelly should be doing so 9/11 an inside
job Sandy Hook stuff animal-human
hybrids which megyn kelly apparently
refuses talk about I believe it's fine
to interview Alex Jones if the context
is right and if it makes sense I believe
if you are going to interview Alex Jones
you have to make it clear as the
interviewer that you're not endorsing
his views that you think he's not that
you'd be properly prepared to push back
at what he says and from the preview
that was released it sort of seems like
megyn kelly was prepared so I have no
problem with this in principle I'd be a
total hypocrite if I said that on
principle
you shouldn't interview Alex joins Jones
that being said I do think this was a
bad choice the platform here is way too
big for Alex Jones it genuinely makes
NBC News and megyn kelly look as if
you've got months and months of buildup
to this major new show and your second
episode or third I don't know you know
one of your first couple episodes is
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones who
thinks public water or fluoride turns
frogs gay this isn't a get in anyway
obviously Alex Jones agreed he's an
attention [ __ ] I think it's more of a
strategic mistake from NBC News let's
see that's interesting now you have
a CNN with W cam bubele on their show
canal bow a show called United shades of
America yep and he's interviewed KKK
leaders he's interviewed Richard Spencer
and other whereas megyn kelly seems to
be pushing back against Alex Jones Bell
just seems to kind of give them that
plat hey I thought that the way he
handled that interview if anyone was
going to criticize me for my interview
with Richard Spencer where were they
with W kamau Bell interview with Richard
Spencer you're absolutely right but that
doesn't change that you know the the
real issue with Alex Jones is not
necessarily the specifics of his
conspiracy theory but the probability or
possibility that his entire stick isn't
even real and is a character that he's
playing which has now been stated in
court by his lawyer I personally
experienced that at a talk radio
conference several years ago and I
described that and the risk was here in
in doing this that the audience would
say what the hell is this I think that
this is just not that makes no sense and
that advertisers would say the same
thing and by the way at least one
advertiser is saying that because
JPMorgan Chase has pulled its
advertisements from NBC News
specifically because of Megyn Kelly's
upcoming interview with Alex Jones
saying that uh this is the the chief
marketing officer of JPMorgan Chase said
I'm repulsed that Kelly would give a
second of airtime to someone who says
sandy hooks
Sandy Hook and Aurora are hoaxes they
are going to not advertise until after
this interview they're going back so
again I think that the strategic mistake
here is what to focus on not the idea of
no platforming Alex Jones but also megyn
kelly has ADD Vladimir Putin on the show
someone who Bill O'Reilly called a
killer someone who goes after people who
oppose him and literally the relevance
of Putin though is unquestionable right
now the relevance of Alex Jones like
yeah they got the one how it was already
pass but is I don't they've Donald Trump
skyping into his program Donald Trump
did appear on Alex Jones's program so
anyway it feels like the platform is
just too big for Alex Jones and that
it's just not again it's sort of a
downside after all this build-up that
this is who Megyn Kelly's is
interviewing but am I offended by this
interview absolutely not I
just don't know that if I was on NBC
News I would choose to interview Alex
Jones you can vote on this though at
david pakman.com our new david
pakman.com poll is asking you to voice
your opinion about megyn kelly choosing
to interview alex jones on our
blockbuster to quote alex jones new show
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show we'll be back after this
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS